Hello Hello BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
Today, we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Thank you for joining us for our 176th episode!
BAU BAU!
Ruffians, you awake?
Out of bed?
Are you a little bit cold?
BAU BAU!
We miss you!
Good morning!
BAU BAU, you awake?
You think so?
Good morning!
It's been what?
How many hours?
Maybe a little bit longer for Ruffians that have got a full rest.
Maybe.
But for Ruffians joining us for the first time, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short for that morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Right now, FUWAMOCO Morning will be brought to you temporarily on Mondays once a week.
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please share your thoughts with the hashtag #FWMCMORNING, okay?
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
A little scratchy, Moco-chan.
Well, there's a bunch of things that happened this week, right?
Yeah.
Scratchy?
No, no.
No FUWAMOCO, right?
Oh, how's Moco-chan's thumb?
Still a bit swollen.
So much gaming huh, Moco-chan?
It was a bunch of fun!
Well, let's start off the week with some brand new news, Moco-chan!
Well... What?
Something almost as spooky as Silent Hill F. Huh?
Because it's autumn?
Because it's October, Moco-chan?
It was...
Pero Sighting.
At least it was that.
Not just something wishy-noshy Moco-chan.
There was a lot of scary things that happened inside the little elf.
Well, let's see how this compares.
Let's take a look!
That sounds very scary.
Ruffians!
Okay.
You approached us down with a bunch of pumpkins.
You picked a very familiar looking pumpkin, right?
No...
Right!
Ruffians, you know that's not a pumpkin.
That's Pero.
You have to be careful, okay?
Be careful, okay?
You know there's a lot of different types of pumpkins here.
Some are orange, lots of orange ones, but some are green, some are white, long, round.
That isn't a pumpkin.
That's not one of them.
No.
Yeah.
So, make sure you don't take it home with you, okay?
Ruffians!
Yeah, just leave it be, okay?
No matter what you ask, don't give it any treats, okay?
Not even candy corn.
No.
What?
Not the candy you don't want either, okay?
Not the pumpkin shaped candy corn either.
That one's better though.
No.
What if he starves?
Let him be.
What if?
What if he doesn't?
But what if you're safe?
I want candy corn.
Just leave it be, okay?
It won't be just nasty Pero.
Okay?
BAU BAU!
You have to be careful.
Comes Christmas, Moco-chan.
Now think of what kind of costume he's going to be putting on then, huh?
Now be careful, careful FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
Wow!
Just over the weekend, there was a very special celebration!
hololive English Promise had their second anniversary!
BAU BAU!
But they also had a special announcement!
They released a brand new original song called Run Back Round!
BAU BAU!
It's a very refreshing and optimistic tune with...
I feel like it feels a bit nostalgic.
Have you listened?
It's a banger!
You love it!
That's so cool!
Right now there's no video at the moment.
You'll have to take a look at their live performance of it during their 2nd anniversary.
You get to see the really cool choreography they have.
It almost makes you want to dance along too.
I'm sure they'll have a very cool MV out soon, so let's look forward to that too!
And in the meantime, you can listen to it on streaming services!
So go check it out!
Run background on Spotify as well!
BAU BAU!
Happy 2nd anniversary, promise!
Please check it out, Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
Oh wow!
There's also another big celebration.
A big milestone that happened just the other day!
Zetta!
She hit 1 million subscribers on YouTube!
Yeah!
Zetta-senpai, congratulations!
Oh Zetta!
Of course, Irene, she hit 1 million subscribers!
It's an amazing feat by Moco-chan!
And she was able to do a countdown stream just in time before she hit the big milestone too!
It's pretty tricky, huh?
Just in time to do an ASMR!
She showed up and then all of a sudden...
I have 1 million!
BAU BAU!
Yeah!
And you know, she was thinking a lot... Maybe about her 1 million wish.
Oh!
I know, we've been thinking a lot about our 1 million.
Yeah!
Quite a while.
But I wonder what she's gonna use it on, huh?
Your outfit?
Maybe.
But actually, I thought it was kind of interesting because it was exactly one year ago that we hit 1 million subscribers too!
It was our anniversary!
And Zettou-senpai and I
BAU BAU!
One year since then.
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for continuing on this journey with us and for letting us protect your smiles.
We're looking forward to many more milestones together with you two!
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
And speaking of milestones...
Oh?
Wow!
Another milestone happened!
Our cover of White Love hit 2 million views on YouTube!
Thank you Ruffians!
BAU BAU!
Wow, White Love won all of a sudden.
It's been a while now, we released it back in December of 2023.
Where does the time go right?
It's a classic song by the 90's idol group SPEED.
It's a very sad and almost in a winter song, but I feel like it's also very powerful.
FUWAMOCO Morning!
One of our best covers!
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
I feel like we were just waking on it the other day.
Why?
Very confusing.
BAU time.
Thank you, Ruffians.
We'll continue to do our best to sing lots and lots.
At least maybe more covers.
BAU BAU!
You know, we always do our best on our music.
For us, our music is really important even if it's a cover song.
Of course, if it's an original song.
We'd be really happy if you could support us by listening to it.
Thank you, Ruffians.
BAU BAU!
And!
A big announcement was made about
hololive Super Expo and hololive Fest!
Did you hear the news, Ruffians?
Yeah!
Oh?
Wow!
De-den!
hololive Fest!
7th hololive Fest is the official title that was now announced.
We have hololive Super Expo 2026.
Makes sense.
And hololive 7th Fest "Ridin'on Dreams"!
Yeah!
I'm so excited!
But this year, you know, it's nice to have a title and everything.
But the dates... Ruffians, are you ready with the calendar?
Make sure you write it down, okay?
In 2026, it will be happening on March 6th, March 7th, and March 8th!
Three days!
That's the first time ever!
Three days of hololive Super Expo at best as well!
Are you ready?
I'm ready!
BAU BAU!
March 7th!
Yeah, March 7th!
March...
6th and 8th, yes.
All of them.
6th, 7th, and 8th, yes!
You need to train your arms right, Ruffians!
It's gonna be an intense three days, so, but let's make it AMAZING!
Last year, or last year, this year, it was our first fest!
What if you don't know what Fes and Expo are?
Expo is a big event the hololive that we all put on.
There's a bunch of different things.
Exhibitions, games, cosplay area, a lot going on.
Special programming, food too.
Yes, that is the big concert that we all worked so hard to prepare.
We put our heart and souls into.
And all of us, all of us at hololive, we're on that big stage there.
So we hope that you can maybe come and cheer us on, whether it's at Makuhari Messe or online with the streaming ticket.
We'd love to have you cheer for us!
It's Wrestle May.
I don't know what that is, but that sounds cool.
Maybe.
Why don't we collaborate?
You know, a bit of both.
I don't think there's gonna be any wrestling this year.
Somehow I doubt it.
It's not wrestling on dreams, Moco-chan.
Ridin'on Dreams.
We know that three days this year means it'll be even bigger and better!
Maybe.
And maybe Justice will be joining us too!
That would be cool.
One can hope.
Swimsuits!
That's too much dreams now, okay?
No.
Yeah, maybe not Ruffians.
No, not that dream.
Yeah.
Okay?
BAU BAU!
I can't wait!
Sighting.
Hope to see you there, Ruffians!
Well, there's some funny stuff going on.
The other day, I'm sure you saw two Ruffians.
First of all, Ruffians.
How would you react if we just tweeted, Ruffians, I need you.
Huh?
Would you be confused?
That would be confusing.
Huh?
Yeah.
Oh?
Well, Abyss, what do you wish for?
Nerissa caused a little bit of a disturbance.
Disturbance.
A panic between everyone.
And I don't know why it was disturbing.
I don't know why it was panicking because it should be understandable.
To some people, there was some suspicious behavior going on on Nerissa's account.
If FUWAMOCO tweeted this, yes, that would be weird.
But Nerissa, Nerissa started tweeting every member of hololive's name along with a, I need you.
Every single member.
JP.
ARIN.
IAN.
The voice.
Why did I think she said I love you?
Moco-chan, that's not what she said.
I thought she said that!
Normal Nerissa thinks right.
Yeah.
The FUWAMOCO.
This is very normal.
We are right there and ready.
For Nerissa.
Yeah.
But there's a lot of different reactions.
Some members thinking you know that her cat was compromised.
Some members upset that she was cheating on them.
They wanted to be the only ones to hear these words.
No.
Nerissa just has a lot of love to give, right?
It's understandable.
It's typical Nerissa.
Ha!
Ruffians!
Deeper is so confused.
Maybe a little bit.
It's not that confusing.
No!
Don't think about it that deeply and it's fine.
Big heart.
Moco-chan, why did you think Nerissa said I love you though?
Because it basically means the same.
That's Chiyo.
She loves everybody at hololive.
BAU BAU!
Typical needy Nerissa.
But you know, it's nice to know that even though it's getting chillier with autumn and everything, Nerissa still has a lot of warmth to provide us.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
FUWAMOCO-chan!
It's the beginning of a brand new week!
It was a fun weekend, but...
But things getting cold.
It's now officially the season where it's hard to get out of bed.
Moco-chan.
Well, did you wanna pup talk?
Huh?
Yeah.
Okay.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
It's that time again!
It's time for a FUWAMOCO Pup Talk!
And you're gonna hear it straight from me!
FUWAMOCO!
Ruffians!
It's October!
It's official, okay.
Has it been a bit colder recently?
I know.
I know it can be hard to get out of bed and get going for the day.
But the faster you spring out of bed and take control of the day, the better!
You'll thank yourself for the fast action.
Got it!
And before you know it, your body and your heart will be all warmed and ready to take on anything!
Okay!
You don't know, it feels like the fall and the winter cold will last forever.
Just remember that BAU time exists!
And we'll be back to the spring before we know it, okay?
Let's do this together!
BAU BAU!
Ganbatte ne!
BAU BAU Moco-chan!
Maybe...
Sorry, I held to go a bit of a...
Bye-bye!
Wow, let's doggy use the Doggie of the Day today, huh?
Doggie of the Day we have... Today's Doggie of the Day is Tsukune-kun Mama!
Look at her big ears!
Smile!
Look at the socks too, Moco-chan!
Tsukune-kun, such a happy boy!
A happy boy who loves to eat too!
Makes sense.
Happy boys love to eat.
How does Tsukune-kun BAU BAU, Moco-chan?
Au revoir!
So happy!
Very very happy bau bau.
Well, I think we can tell right from this photo here.
He's the best boy you could ever wish to have by your side.
Always ready to play.
Always ready to go for a walk.
Just wants to be next to you.
What are you straight for?
Today I went on a walk.
Let's see, where did we go for a walk today?
De-den!
Autumn fireworks!
Amazing!
It looks like purple!
It looks like a heart.
Like a heart or a jellyfish!
Wow, so beautiful!
We're glad you're able to go with your family too!
We got to come along as well!
FUWAMOCO, have we ever watched Violet?
Not in the autumn.
You know autumn fireworks in the summer time, ya?
But not too much really.
I feel like autumn is sort of rare.
But it would be nice.
These are so pretty.
We're glad you had a nice time.
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
And next we have our Question of the Day!
Today's Question of the Day is...
De-den!
Spooky season is upon us, so...
I know you're a powerful team of guide dogs, but what sends shivers down your spines?
Ghosts?
Spiders?
Vampires?
Or something else?
Spiders is more or less... Ruffians, what do you think the answer is, huh?
Spiders aren't spooky.
Important question.
Yeah, not... nothing.
I don't know about that.
Onions?
Pearl?
We're not scared of Pearl, right Moco-chan?
No.
No?
What?
What do you think?
I don't know.
We didn't even go on dogs!
We're getting stronger too, right Moco-chan?
We're not scared of heights!
Not really.
A reasonable level?
We're not scary cats.
We're strong demon guard dogs.
But maybe all of those, you know?
I think anything that's surprising and kinda scary...
Right?
That doesn't right?
If anything was to jump all at me, that would be enough.
Even my shadow scares me sometimes.
Yeah.
Loud noises?
Oh.
Very much so.
Some washing machine noises.
All the time, right?
Not me.
FUWAMOCO-san.
Huh?
What do you mean not you, Moco-chan?
Not because I'm aware of it.
You're always scared of it.
No I'm not.
The answer is more or less anything.
Yeah.
Just something.
But we're getting stronger, right, Moco-chan?
Thank you Ruffians!
Thank you for your submissions!
Remember, if you have a doggy of a day or have questions, walks that you went on, or love for Chip Pero Sighting, please send us with the hashtag!
Hashtag!
FWMCMORNING!
Especino...
The fall season, maybe going on some nice walks?
Please share that with us, okay?
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
And wow, for Ruffians joining us in the archives, FUWAMOCO's word is...
It's BAU BAU, all the lives!
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for joining us for another FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Mr. Yabu Yabu!
BAU BAU!
Lion.
Tuna.
BAU BAU!
Whale.
Ibukuro.
BAU BAU!
Bull.
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!